[Applause]
truth martha stewart and uh you're going
to show me some stuff what are you going
to show me well yes for some reason
everyone is fascinated with folding a
t-shirt
and i've done this a few times on my
show everyone's fascinated by folding
drawers of america are getting neater
and more organized every single day uh
this is something that i'm terrible i
just uh i just take the t-shirt and kind
of well i'm not an idiot
no what i do is i just kind of like fold
it in half and then fold it like that
and then it's just always messy later on
so watch wow you'll help me okay don't
don't do it with me just watch you grab
halfway
between the neck and the shoulder
halfway between the neck of the shoulder
you pinch then take a straight line this
way down to the hem and you pinch
halfway okay got it yeah now you take
your left hand over your right hand down
to the hem and pinch again don't let go
of anything
pull out like this i've never heard this
level of desperation you know pull out
like this and fold over and there you
have the perfectly folded t-shirt
that's good look at that
you want to try yes okay now i will
speak and you will not interrupt me all
right
i'll be quiet i pinch here right about
there on the shoulder what on the
shoulder
that is the shoulder oh at the very tip
yeah all right there your one
interruption's been used
i pinch here i carry it then i pinch
here
okay and then i fold over to this point
and i grab and i don't let go of
anything exactly
and now what do you do
i'm so lost right now i pull this out
yeah don't let go don't let go of
anything shake shake
lay down flat lay down flat fold over
no no all the way what's this what
happened over
the directions are right on the back see
the directions are on the back
that's a cool
t-shirt takes some of hey you're sure it
looks good but oh yeah those are the
directions on the back
just in case you want to practice at
home okay i'll now forget that
immediately let's move on okay so we
wanted you to do certain things too
because with halloween coming
halloween's coming thanksgiving and the
pies being baked and everything i wanted
you to learn how to um spiral an apple
spiral and apple so do you know what
this is this looks like something you
built while you were away this is
[Music]
this is a great thing this is really a
very old fashioned now this has a little
suction thing that's a suction cup where
do you find these watch watch
watch what this does this is brilliant
you've never seen this no that blew my
mind look at that
watch that there you have a spiral apple
but isn't that cute
yeah but it fell apart why did it fall
apart
i i should have been holding it
underneath oh okay and what do you do
with this part right here the little
core part well you just pull it off like
that and what can this be used is this
an accessory is this anything whatever
you want whatever you can save this but
you like to save everything i know and
then these are little floating votives
do you like floating voters don't you
think this is cute that's a very nice
idea so people come over kids come over
for halloween and you give them some
candy and then you say look some apples
with candles floating right now you can
you can do this yourself use
[Applause]
but you can hollow this out with a
little melon ball scoop and you have
that at home right i don't have one of
these at home
i'm gonna go buy a t-shirt i gotta start
with that okay so you have to you can
score this around like this but why
don't you hollow that out a little
bigger so that you can put a candle
right in it like that okay and so you
just make sure you see how nice that is
it works really nice so a melon baller
and an exacto knife yes and you too can
make a candle right and then you just
float the apple in there and then how
was that is that okay yeah fine you
don't love this do you you think i
didn't do a good job fine
and then light the candle and then you
have another one okay but this is the
most fun of all is we don't have another
candle for some reason
i just like that there's one without a
candle that's it's very creates a whole
thing about society
and halloween parties that you're going
to have this year because your little
daughter wants a halloween we're gonna
have a halloween party this year but i
thought uh apple dunking do you remember
apple dunking from your childhood
bobbing for apples
so you have to have your hands tied
behind your back
but all right
all right you make that as tight as you
want to martha
there yeah okay now you can bob i had
this dream once all right
you were there and i was tied and
there were no apples um
so what do i do now oh i remember this
bob give me an apple give you oh and say
it like really say it like give me an
apple
in a very domineering way
just just please give me enough oh it
doesn't work that way it's still okay
give you an apple all right so i'm just
gonna
that is hard how do you get your
can't grab
you just
[Applause]
oh
now now look at the mess you've made
i've been bad
martha stewart the apprentice uh martha
stewart airs wednesday nights at 8 on
nbc
and martha airs weekdays check your uh
local listings i'm going to be on
tomorrow and uh you're going to dry my
hair during the commercial you're quite
good at drawing hair are you lovely
we'll be right back big shows on the
show
you